[Music]
with this screen
rachel hi hey
hi
uh everything okay bud
not really what are you doing this is
gonna sound really crazy but i'm gonna
need to see that ring for just one
second one second have you lost your
mind i'm gonna give it right back i
promise you guys please randall it's
really important can i no bro go sit
down randall give me the ring please
just okay randall don't look at him look
at me brandon randall right one second
put the ring on my finger no reina
listen to me randall look at me ring on
my face give me the ring give me just
one second put a ring on it
please love okay
with this ring yes i'm so sorry about
that
[Music]
anybody hurt
sonic ah hawaii
these rings signify the commitment
so help me thomas sorry sorry
life or death situation i need you to
use the ring to save me like right now
snowmaker oh boy
ah hawaii i just hope we are not too
late oh lord there are two of them now
what's happening okay quick version
robotnik is back
i discovered the source of ultimate
power
we need to get it back for the world is
doomed
you got some kind of
space porcupine
i am an echidna warrior
hmm
hedgehog
it's time to say goodbye to humanity
this is your moment to be the big hero
bad time to say this but i don't
actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh
someone call an uber
it's cold in here
let's turn up the heat
oh great the winter soldier
fear not citizens you are terrible at
this your negative attitude is not
helping
we stick together
no matter what
you're unskilled
untrained
unworthy
you forgot one
unstoppable
[Music]
knuckles you are really bad at punching
[Music]
you